si votre médecin généraliste était une
intelligence artificielle VO des
résultats encourageants sur la capacité
d'un logiciel à établir un diagnostic
médical fiable ont été présenté par une
étude américaine les études elles sont
toujours américaines on dirait qu'il y a
queux qui travaillent non mais c'est il
jamais d'études c'est que au États-Unis
qui a les études c'est un truc de fou on
dirait qu'icici nous on fout rien
regardez l'intelligence artificielle
commence à s'imisser de plus en plus
dans nos vies un outil numérique qui
fascine par ses différentes capacités
mais qui en inquiète aussi certains car
aujourd'hui l'intelligence artificielle
pourrait même remplacer nos docteurs et
si votre médecin généraliste était una
une entreprise américaine a récemment
développé un outil doté d'étonnante
capacité à l'aide d'un questionnaire le
patient doit tout d'abord comme avec un
vrai médecin décrire ses symptômes et
livrer des informations sur sa santé
quelques instants plus tard
l'intelligence artificielle lui fournit
un diagnostic un diagnostic qui selon
une récente étude savère fiable dans 82
% des
cas alors est-ce que ça vous fait peur
ça e les médecins bientôt remplacés par
l'intelligence artificielle Gill Verdez
paniqué et j'espère que ça ne verra
jamais le jour toi franchement de toute
façon tu seras plus là hein euh non
franchement on n peut plus 82 % des cas
sont résolus par l'intelligence
artificielle qui trouve la maladie et
les 18 % restant il meurent vous vous
rendez compte Cyril c'est l'erreur
médicale assurée mais c'est l'erreur
médicale assurée l'intelligence elle
fait n'importe quoi 5 minutes 25
questions pour trouver une maladie vous
connaissez bien la
médecine exactement c'est n'importe quoi
c'est l'homme c'est le médecin qui doit
diagnostier
RCR DISI là dislui tu dit de la merde B
il le sait j'espère DEP temps quand même
non mais attends non non mais c'est moi
je trouve ça incroyable parce que c'est
c'est l'avenir toi tu veux toujours tu
refuses au progrès un homme du Moyen-Âge
dès qu'il y a quelque chose qui va dans
le sens de l'avenir tout de suite tu es
les pieds sur les freins et cetera tout
le monde sait c'est pour ça qu'on s'en
effraye d'ailleurs que l'intelligence
artificielle va ouvrir plein de
nouvelles pores et cetera mais toi tu
veux rester quel feutré derrière tes m
quoi les médecins ils existeront
toujours comme les ordinateurs n' pas
remplacé les écrivains comme comme les
fusé n'ont pas remplacé les avions voilà
on avance voilà laissenous avancer not
comme les sexto nont pas remplacé rocoss
Freddy le projet c'est quand même de
remplacer l'humain en l'occurrence doné
la parole personne merci
alandre Alexandre vouz parler moi je
parle pour mon cas mon accident c'est
une erreur médicale négligence fauteuse
d'un hôpital donc moi je vois le l comme
une comme une solution
hyper positive parce que lia elle est
contrôlée par l'humain mais elle va
pouvoir permettre de réduire justement
peut-être une certaines erreurs euh
notamment moi par exemple c'était un
problème de dosage et donc du coup li
j'imagine qu'on peut programmer enfin
voilà donc je pense qu'il faut être
positif et et voir le l'amélioration
comme du positivisme et pas avoir peur
de pas avoir peur de demainaméliation
peur de tout tu vois pas qu'il a peur
deù tu as raison là là où tu as raison
c'est effectivement que
c'est c'est in avancé faut pas que ce
soit pour remplacer le médecin faut que
ce soit pour accompagner le médecin or
là on veut nous le vendre en nous disant
comme il y a des déserts médicaux on
mettra des à la place et on va palier
l'absence de médecin par par ces
machines non en fait il faut que ce
soit toute seule parce que je me suis
dit que c'était bien non non déjà pas
content parce que y a
gueule alors pour moi justement la
médecine c'est de la science et de la
science c'est A+ B+ C voilà symptômes
plus symptômes plus symptômes plus
symptômes égale maladie et donc du coup
pour moi une machine s'il y a beaucoup
de questions peut vraiment se rapprocher
de la bonne maladie pourra donc donner
des ordonnances par exemple dans les
déserts médicaux commençons par mettre
ces machines là dans les déserts
médicaux comme ça toute la surface
française est recouverte par des
médecins et comme ça on peut avoir ses
ordonnances donc c'est unement sur une
jambe de bois et après non des fras 1802
mon frère c'est un pement sur une
jambe
phine quand par ah ce ou pardon j'avais
oublié la chouche c'est vrai suite vrai
parlerphine a raison en fait non mais on
a aussine Alexandre c'est mes chouchous
avec cardose également et Pascal tour
duupain et donc c'est vrai que quand on
va chez le médecin aussi jusqu'à présent
on aime le contact humain parce qu'on
aime raconter ses bobos il y a un petit
côté aussi un peu psychologique pour ça
il existe d'autres médecins et ça on
pourra jamais supplanter par par les la
mécanique qui s'appelle qui s'appelle le
Py
ça dev c'est trop long non le
psychologueine a raison raison RA
raisonour a raison mais je suis pas
d'accord avec elle alors ellephine a
raison mais je ne suis pas d'accord avec
elle parce que je pense que ce sera un
mix entre les deux alors pourquoi pas
l'intelligence artificielle mais que
fais-tu de la palpation que fais-tu
decultation que fais-tu des play qu'on
peut qu' que une intelligence
artificielle ne pourra pas voir enfin
malgré tout je pense que ce sera quand
même très très limité quand les femmes
vont se faire palper je sais pas par du
ventre ou les seins ou des ganguillons
et tout ça l'intelligence artificielle
pardon c'est pas une question de
psychologue c'est une question de
médecin et d'aptitude d'un médecin et je
suis sûr que votre papa il est tout à
fait d'accord avec moi mon papa il est
pas d'accord avec vous il est d'accord
qu'avec moi peut-être que vous êtes
d'accord avec
moi il nous retarde dans l'avancée
technologique on pourrait déjà bien plus
loin s'il y avait pas des gens comme
Gill et Géraldine incroyable oui c'est
incroou laiss
parler quelqu non non non mais ça mais
non l'humain sera toujours là important
pour savoir mais j'adore la
machine non j'ai une question à Gilles
Gilles j'imagine que tu es contre la
suppression des pilotes dans le cockpit
d'un avion mais c'est cette question là
c'est une question c'est toi qui incarne
la modernité mais tu as V ta
[Applaudissements]
gueulec oui jacqu tu l'as réveillé
là je totalement d'accord avec
Jean-Michel attend mais c'est que en
face
làir ils sont ils ont peur de l'avenir
ils ont peur du futur et vous jouez à
vous faire peur à chaque fois qu'on voit
des robots c'est mon dieu c'est horrible
on va tous mourir ils vont tous nous
remplacer mais c'estidment pas ça dans
la
caricature c'est pas ça c'est comme une
application ça ça va remplacer juste t
application simplement ça va être
beaucoup plus évolué ça va permettre de
donner déjà un premier avis voilà c'est
c'est un premier attends attends finir
PL oui je voulais finir g si tu as si tu
luisais un peu excuse-moi voilà au lieu
de regarder que du foot tout le temps tu
saurais que le seul fait qu' a encore
des pilotes dans un avion c'est pour un
problème psychologique parce que les
Français enfin les gens en général ont
peur d'un avion qui n'est pas piloté par
les hommes si c'était les machines qui
pilotaient les avions j' Auris 80
% Maule franchement là il faut que tu
tranquille non j'articule
exprès
com j'ai dit on maintient les pilotes
dans les avions pour un côté
psychologique parce que les gens se
disent s'il y a un problème dans l'avion
le pilote voudra sauver sa vie et du
coup il sauvera la nôtre voil alors
qu'aujourd'hui on
pourrait et s avait pas laissez-moi
terminer par contre non et s'il y avait
pas de pilote dans un avion ça
supprimerait 80 % des accidents des
crash tu le savais ça maintenant tu le
sais voilà mais parce que les machines
sont bien plus performantes par que je
mais tu lis
[Applaudissements]
quoi chez vous il est 19h58 les chériis
il y a Jean-Michel mer qui vient dire un
truc et je voudrais m'arrêter là-dessus
que c'est incroyable votre chiffre il y
aurait ouais moins d'accidents s'il avit
pas de pilote 80 % d'accidents de Mo
c'est dans quel magazine dans mais mais
vous sortez
discuté avec des scientifiques je sa pas
o tu as discuté avec des scientifiqu
mais tu as discuté avec qui toi où tu as
discuté avec scientifiques dans quelle
boîte échang mais franchement au tou
chou à Chatou il y a un peu de
scientifique je suis désolé j' j'en ai
pas vu beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup la
chose aéronautique c'est pour ça
s'intéresse à la chose c'est la même
chose par exemple pour les voitures les
voitures on dit bientôt pour Google il y
aura bientôt des voitures sans
conducteur s'il y avait 10 % dans Paris
10% de voitures sans conducteur il y
aurait 50 % de bouchon au moins tu le
savais ça ça non plus tu le savais pas
[Applaudissements]
chose tu plz vous les connaissez aussi
maisù mais qu'est-ce que vous faites le
soir quand vous rentrez moi je B C
émission je sais pas je savais qu'on
avait parlé de ça je me suis renseigné
biblthè j'ai ouvert des livres des
cumoir
mais mais parce que j'adore moi je je
vais je passe beaucoup de temps sur
internet et dès qu'il y a le papier
sur c'est vrai qu'il et les papiers
scientifiques tout ça ça me passionne
sur ça aussi oui parce que ça arrive
aussi dans le porno
effectivement attendsends donc tes
chiffres sont vrais bien sûr qu'il sont
CZ que je me permettrai de balancer les
chiffres comme ça ou c'est pas
faux vérifier faites votre boulot non
mais tu as vu quand il dis ça qu'est-ce
que tu lui répond c'estraisemblable
c'est un délire total inventé il a il a
inventé CIN chiffres C flush brelandas
Tom poker oui 50 % des voitures mais
tues la gueule de qui d'où tuas bossé tu
sais même pas ce qu'il y a dans le
conducteur regarde arrête Jean-Michel
moi j'en ai marre g je te dira ch qu'est
qu'il y a dans le conducteur voilà
l'autre foisand fin c'est toi Einstein
qui c'est tu te compares Einstein
maintenant mais arrêtez c'est bon là
c'est
[Applaudissements]
bon pour le conducteur après il a
vas-y
term par de
Fran vas-y on est avec toi on est avec
toiin attendsends reprends tout début
asy Gilles oui Einstein a dit un jour
attends attend quoi quoi Einstein a dit
un jour si nous n'avançons pas dans la
dans la vie reprendsla
reprends g Einstein a dit un jour si
nous n'avançons pas dans la vie
reprends
non non mais attends attends reprends
REP de là fais des cisures fais des
césures Gilles oui Einstein a dit un
jour si nous n'avançons pas dans la vie
ce n'est pas à cause des choses que nous
ignorons c'est à cause des choses que
nous
croyons vrai et qui sont fausses comme
toi tuas tu as des idées en tête mais
c'est faux c'est faux oui c'est Einstein
évidemment Roger Einstein c'est
un bravo bravo là làut
à mon avis à mon avis c'est un Tunisien
quiit c'est M non là vous me Chariez
vous savez tout
ça il a pas dit qu'il n'avance pas recul
exact ouais je sais non non alors et
donc qu'est-ce que voilà il il est il
est muré d'ailleurs derrière les portes
du passé et il veut pas écouter il veut
pas mettre en doute c'est pere
reconnaissance si tu remettais un peu en
doute ce que qu'on t'a appris peut-être
par des gens sans mauis volonté mais
voilà qu' t'ont mis des choses fausses
dans la tête tu t'ouvrirais à d'autres
mondes et tu avancerais là tu es englué
comme une merde
ah oui plutôt il y a quelqu'un qui me
dit alors je vous dis c'est
contreintuitif mais ces avions sans
pilotes seraiit plus sûr que ceux
d'aujourd'hui les erreurs de pootage
sont à l'origine de 80 % des accidents
on supprime donc tout risque de
défaillance du pilote en l'air comme le
drame de la Gman Wings où un pilote
avait foncé volontairement dans une
montagne JeanMichel les chiffres sont
bons
attendez par définition par définition
tous les crashes par définition tous les
crashes que les pilot ont sauvé on en
parle pas puisqu'ils ont sauvé les
crashes tes pilotes donc par définition
un pilote quand il sauve un crash c'est
vrai aussi qui non parce que y a 80 %
des crashes d'avion sont du à des
erreursê quand le pilote a sauvé le
crash tu es pas au courant puisqueil y a
pas eu de crash tu dit quoi tu as des
problèmes mais l'ordinateur l'aurait
fait aussi n'importe quoi puisque y la
première chose qu'on apprend au pilote
c'est dès qu'il y a un problème vous
appuyez sur pilote automatique parce
qu'ils savent que l'ordinateur va mieux
Riv je sais pas si un
robot s parce que justement c'est
incroyable incroyable il mais sur sur
les
voitures sur les avions il a dit vrai
les gens voitures aussi voitur 10 %
c'est ça 10 % 10 % de voitures sans
conducteur c'est 50 % de bouchons au
moins dans Paris c'est normal ça coûte
trop cher du coup il y a plus de voiture
merci le déb là je veux bien en parler
aussi parce que j'ai
connais qui bah sur l'économie des
transports et cetera mais je pense qu'
faudrait faire une émission entière sur
il est polyvalent ouais c'est tout
parler dans un instant tu restes avec
nous dans un instant